und jetzt schauen wir in den Bundestag
gestern stimmt die EU im Parlament für
ein grünes Ökolabel für Atomkraftwerke
und Erdgas das heißt beide
Energiequellen gelten damit als
nachhaltig ja und jetzt spricht unser
Bundesumweltminister Robert Habeck von
den Grünen eben im Bundestag dabei nutzt
habe ich auch die Möglichkeit die
Opposition anzugehen die Opposition
bezeichnete die Politik der Ampel als
schönwetterpolitik habe ich Meinung dazu
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
buchstäblich steht Deutschland im Regen
hätten wir diese Pakete vor 10 Jahren
durchgezogen wir würden ganz anders
heute darstellen
insofern dass wir hier machen
was wir hier machen ist Deutschland
wieder in eine energiepolitische sichere
Zukunft zu führen vielen Dank ja gerade
eben angesprochen dass EU-Parlament in
Straßburg das hat sich entschieden
atomkraft ja bitte die Parlamentarier
die haben in einer Abstimmung
Atomenergie als nachhaltig eingestuft
also ab jetzt klimafreundlich und
förderungswürdig gefällt jetzt nicht
unbedingt jedem in Deutschland
diese Entscheidung sorgt für mächtig
Wirbel das EU-Parlament verpasst der
Kernenergie ein Ökolabel stuft sie als
klimafreundlich und nachhaltig ein für
die Grünen ein absoluter Albtraum der
hier jetzt wartet der Kampf gegen die
Kernenergie er gehört zum
Gründungsmythos der Grünen Brokdorf
Gorleben Wackersdorf keine andere Partei
in Deutschland ist so sehr mit der
anti-akkw-bewegung verbunden für die
Grünen kommt diese Entscheidung pro
Atomkraft zur Unzeit seit Dezember sind
sie an der Macht und doch können sie
diese Entscheidung nicht verhindern
anders als in Österreich will die
Bundesregierung gegen diese Entscheidung
nicht einmal klagen die neu gewonnene
macht sie wird für bärbock Habeck und Co
schon nach einem halben Jahr zur
klimapolitischen Ohnmacht die von
Kanzler Scholz beschworene zeitenwände
sie schlägt also auch bei den Grünen
jetzt voll durch allein der Krieg in der
Ukraine zwingt die Partei zu
schmerzhaften Kompromissen im März reist
Habeck nach Katar verbeugt sich vor den
Machthabern und tötet mit dem golfstart
eine Energiepartnerschaft für Flüssiggas
ein und auch beim Thema
Waffenlieferungen vollzieht die einstige
pazifistenpartei eine schwindelerregende
Kehrtwende schwere Waffen in ein
Kriegsgebiet für grüne bis vor kurzem
undenkbar und jetzt zählen sie zu den
stärksten Befürwortern und die Debatte
um die Laufzeitverlängerung sie nimmt in
Europa jetzt wieder an Fahrt auf das
neue Ökolabel explodierende
Energiepreise für die
anti-atomkraftgrünen wird es langsam eng
in Finnland jedenfalls da Scheren die
Grünen bereits aus setzen auf die
Atomkraft als das kleinere Übel und
sehen sie als wichtigen Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz und hier bei uns das Nein
zur Kernenergie es bleibt das letzte
Kernstück von Bündnis 90 die Grünen
fragt sich nur wie lange noch
und darüber müssen wir sprechen wir sind
jetzt verbunden mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler Albrecht von
Lücke Herr von Lucke die Bundesregierung
hat gestern gesagt sie wolle nicht gegen
den Beschluss des EU-Parlaments klagen
bringt das den Koalitionspartner die
Grünen in die Bredouille
nein das wird uns meines Erachtens nicht
tun denn es ist ja eines ganz
bemerkenswert in der Tat sie haben das
im Beitrag zurecht angesprochen viele
der Überzeugung der Grünen sind jetzt
ein Stück weit einem Realitätscheck
unterworfen aber das ganz bemerkenswerte
ist doch die grüne Wählerschaft begreift
dass in dieser Situation eines Krieges
offensichtlich andere Anforderungen an
die Partei gestellt werden die Aktien
nennen wir es mal ökonomisch also die
Werte von Annalena baerberg und Robert
Habeck steigen regelrecht in den Himmel
das heißt die Akzeptanz für die Grünen
grünen Politiker ist gerade nicht in
Niedergang und deshalb ist es ganz
auffällig dass dieser ich nenne es
einmal Deal und da ist es wirklich der
ist fatal diese Entscheidung das
Gütesiegel der Taxonomie denn das ist es
es soll eigentlich bedeuten dass
Energieformen wie Atom aber auch Gas
ausgezeichnet sind als nachhaltig das
ist natürlich Greenwashing aber meines
Erachtens wird es diese Koalition nicht
belasten denn sie hat fatalerweise das
muss man schon sehen das begriffen in
der Hinsicht das letztlich man im Zuge
des Krieges diese Kompromisse machen
muss und anders als Österreich wird hier
nicht geklagt weil es durchgewunken wird
aber langfristig ist dieser Ausweis das
Gas aber auch Atom gewissermaßen jetzt
belobigt werden natürlich fatal weil
damit in Industrien investiert wird die
auf Dauer nicht gut auch für die Umwelt
nicht gut sind das heißt sie gehen davon
aus dass diese Entscheidungen die die
Grünen jetzt treffen die eigentlich gar
nicht so im in erster Linie zur Partei
passen Ihnen möglicherweise für die
Zukunft sogar noch ein Aufschwung geben
das ist sehr pointiert formuliert das
sehe ich nicht aber es wird so sein es
wird natürlich Proteste berechtigte
Proteste geben seitens aller
Umweltverbände auf Fridays for future
wird berechtigterweise protestüben aber
wir müssen momentan erleben dass die
Wählerschaft der Grünen in hohem Maße
erkannt hat dass erstens die
Kriegssituation andere Dinge erfordert
und sie hatten vorhin so schön
geschrieben regieren sich die Grünen
jetzt schwarz oder werden sie schwarz
regiert wir haben ja auch Robert Habeck
gehört Robert Habeck Kontakt mit einem
gewissen recht wir tätigen momentan
Notwehr deshalb weil über 16 Jahre eine
Energiewende zu erneuerend erneuerbaren
energierbaren Energien unter der
Regierung Merkel verschlafen wurde das
heißt das wird von der Wählerschaft
durchaus akzeptiert die große Frage ist
tatsächlich ob was gerade jetzt die
Anerkennung von Atomkraft anbelangt die
ja natürlich man muss es sagen auf
co2-fragen betont nachhaltig ich nenne
es mal in engeren Sinne ist also keine
CO2-Ausstoß hat aber nachhaltig in einem
weiteren Sinne überhaupt niemals sein
kann da weder Endlager existieren
geschweige denn ein Atommüll der über
10.000 von Jahren weiter strahlt so
etwas wie nachhaltig sein kann da ist
die Frage dann schon ob das den Grünen
nicht noch auf die Füße fällt aber wir
erleben gerade dass diese Wählerschaft
momentan bereit ist sehr viele
Kompromisse zu begreifen und deswegen
sehe ich nicht das ist zu einer
Zerreißprobe für die Grünen wird wir
behalten das natürlich im Blick vielen
Dank Politikwissenschaftler Albert von
Lucke für ihre Analyse hier
ich danke Ihnen